avril 2011
düsseldorf en allemagne je m'échauffe et
je me prépare compétition internationale
de danse hip hop l'antichambre de
paris-bercy mythique scène légendaire
je me prépare des années des années de
travail
je passe la qualification je danse et
après plus de neuf ans de travail je
perd au premier tour
là c'est le chaos total dans ma tête
tout est terminé
tous ces sacrifices personnels
professionnels en une soirée ont été
gâchées sur le moment c'est une réalité
cela faisait très mal je ne veux plus
rester dans ce contexte je sors de
l'événement je sillonne les rues
düsseldorf en marchant les larmes
coulent tout seul c'est très très
difficile
je ne sais pas quoi faire je retourne à
la maison toute la rue dieu doute me
remets en question aient envie d'arrêter
j'ai vraiment envie de tout lâcher c'est
la fin deux mois après je rentre juin
2011 je relève la tête et je décide de
combattre de me relever après cet échec
dix ans de travail je me dis c'est pas
au bout de dix ans de travail que tu va
abandonner je me relève
je travaille et à force d'acharnement
avril 2012
un an plus tard je deviens champion de
france en danse looking à aix en
provence
de là tout s'enchaîne je passe de la
passion à la vocation de la scène
amateur à la scène professionnelle et
donc ce soir je vais vous laisser
découvrir l'envergure de ce talent
enfin je pensais car la réalité m'a
rattrapé il est clair aujourd'hui qu'il
est difficile de définir la frontière
entre l'outil et l'homme car je suis à
la fois l'outil mais aussi l'homme est
une réalité telle que la blessure m'a
rattrapé il ya voilà cela quinze jours
que j'étais en train de préparer cette
intervention en me disant très
simplement
qu'est ce que je vais prendre présenté
ce soir un beau show le show qu'on
présente de manière classique et cette
question cette problématique mais venu
où se situe la limite entre l'outil l
homme dans mon domaine où est la
frontière entre et entre l'outil est
l'homme l'homme que je suis le voudrait
bien mais l'outil que je représente ce
soir en a décidé autrement
c'est pourquoi à force de réflexion il a
été question d'avoir une réponse
et cette réponse est l'adaptation
aujourd'hui l'homme que je suis va vous
donner le meilleur de ce que mon outil
peut accomplir ce soir à vous d'en juger
dans
m